it's so so easy for a child to be
groomed online
you know even on platforms like whatsapp
all it takes is for one person to get
your child's contact number and they're
put into a into a group
you know a whatsapp group where they
could be sort of 20 or 30 pedophiles
just
start requesting pictures it's a madness
[Music]
should have done a vocal warm-up show hi
i'm mike from dark light and i'm a
paedophile hunter
perfect is that okay yeah
right all right let's start so how did
you get into it um
i experienced some some things as a as a
child that i really shouldn't have gone
through
um that i never got justice for i never
got answers for
so it kind of took me to
a dark place i was in a a dark place for
a lot of years
and then i saw one day after having
multiple breakdowns on facebook that
there was
um i peed up a live video of a pedophile
being stung
and it just it intrigued me
um so i contacted the team and and i
asked
you know what what i needed to do to be
to be able to help and it just it
started from there
so can you take us through it step by
step
in detail so what's the first thing you
do
so we we set up dormant profiles on
social media platforms that are you know
sort of full of children um
facebook snapchat instagram all of the
major platforms
we will set up you know a dormant decoy
profile
and we will make that profile appear
like it's that of a child with you know
various different
methods and we'll await contact
just you know little little things
you know putting pictures of horses
online i'm as a decoy because i decoy my
own work as well
as a decoy i'm going you know if i'm in
tesco's and i'm or
asdas or wherever it is and i'm buying
something i'll take a picture of
something in the store and i'll upload
it to my instagram
so it looks like i'm out shopping with
my nana or i'm out doing
you know you've you've got a look
like you're a child the the next steps
uh we're contacted um by
a suspect profiler you know as soon as
it comes through to us it's always
viewed as a suspect profile because it's
making contact with what appears to be a
young girl's profile um contact will be
made and at the first point of contact
from the other side will
initiate contact with them will return
contact but will never
send the first message ever um
and from that obviously they'll find out
how old we are in the first couple of
sentences and and from there
um they'll i'd say 98
of them continue on into sexual
conversation we can go from
somebody going through a long grooming
process whereas they'll take
months to try and build a relationship
with you or
to build a friendship so you trust them
and then
there's other ones that will just come
on straight away
they'll ask for naked pictures and then
you know block you afterwards or they'll
they'll skip through profiles they'll
use various different tactics to try and
target one child
we start to build a profile of who that
person is looking through facebook
looking through
online registries trying to locate
that obviously using the child decoy um
we're able to obtain evidence and
information about that person so what we
can gradually do is build the case
together we can see who's living in
the property where that person's living
we can see
you know we can find out what job that
person does we can find out
you know through google and different
resources
whether they've got any past convictions
that have gone through court
there's you know it's a it's a long long
process but
as soon as they start to go in that
direction we'll start an investigation
i'll give the go ahead to start an
investigation and we'll
try and get everything that we can
looking at you know
the small things facial profiles tattoos
um car registrations brickwork details
on people's houses and
you know it really is quite extensive
what we go into all right
let's just start off with your uh
wristbands and face shots so just look
straight ahead mike we're gonna look in
uh
here and jim's gonna do a little pan
across your face but just keep looking
in my hand
so the sting is like it's it's the end
of our process but the start of the
legal process
um and when we stink we you know
typically we'll go out and meet
um the the pedophiles after they've
arranged to meet with
the child that they're speaking to um
and then from there obviously we'll
we'll apprehend him
um nine times out of ten it'll it'll go
on facebook unless there's safeguarding
issues around
where we are you know children in the
area things like that
we've got to be really careful because
you know with
while it's not a massive platform we've
got we've got some kind of social
responsibility that we need to be doing
things
correctly in in the best interest of the
community that we're in
i'm not going to go into what is
required for us to go out and do a
successful sting but there are certain
elements of the chat that need to be
there to enable us to get a prosecution
so
you know it sometimes it is a waiting
game um
and what we have to do kind of in the
meantime is make sure that
try and make sure that they're not
speaking to any other children
how do you do that um
mainly by either contacting social
services contacting the police
um you know there's there's not just
it's a very gray area in what we do
because there's
there are people online that are
vulnerable themselves so we have to risk
assess everything that comes through us
we're not professionally trained
um in in the sense of of running risk
assessments but i've been doing it long
enough to kind of get a grasp of
you know what's what's right and what's
wrong and the right way to do things so
for instance if we get someone who
starts speaking to one of the decoys and
we suspect that that person might have
some kind of learning difficulties
contact at that point is stopped and
then we'll reach out to adult social
services
how do you feel before you go on this
thing
i think it's the you know it's the same
feeling i've i've
stung a lot of
different sexual predators from all
different walks of life and
now i'm used to the same
it's the same parts are the same they
come out with the same excuses are was
hacked or
you know i didn't know what i was doing
or i was drunk or
you know all these different things and
and for me
like all of those
it doesn't matter you know who you are
all of those factors should not
make you want to go and harm a child or
do the things that they do online
so what we do in in essence is we you
know will arrive at the meeting place
we'll tell them who we are pull them to
the side away from
you know public and
we'll confront them with the evidence
that we've got but as we confront them
the police are being contacted
um by another member of the team and
then the police will obviously attend
and arrest them based on the evidence
that we've
that we've got and you know the
the sting is we the reason that we live
stream it to facebook is simply to
one um make sure that no allegations can
be made of any
wrongdoing on our part but also at the
same time from an evidential point of
view because if when we're
questioning this person about what
they're doing
if they admit it then obviously that
that can be used in court against them
okay try to talk us through a case what
is an example of the case that you're
like this is um
what kind of case like do you want do
you want the worst of the worst
what's the one you feel proudest of
we had a team of d cars working for us
and
um the guy was under a profile called
danny williams on facebook and
within the the pedophile hunting
community if that's what you want to
call it
there's there's various different teams
various different independent decoys you
don't do it for teams you know it is a
big
um a big buildup of people that are all
doing it for the right reasons anyway we
had made contact with another team who
had him
and was speaking to him but we didn't
know who he was
we didn't you know because he was hiding
behind a fake profile
um so
i had to take a risk because it was
getting progressively worse he was
talking about bullying the kids talking
about you know
um anal sex with the kids and it just
got really really bad
to the point where i was even telling my
decoys not to engage in conversation
because it was just vile he was a bullet
um a narcissistic bullet and
[Music]
we he was from khan forth near marcum
so we went to khan forth um
we turned up at his address and his dad
invited us in
and when his dad invited us in um his
dad said i think i've got an idea what
it's about because he's been arrested
for something like this before so he was
already
released under investigation so he was
under investigation at that point and
then we turned up and
and stunned him um i couldn't go live on
that occasion
because we was we've been invited into
the property and obviously there's
privacy laws and things
um but i put a picture of him on the
page probably
half an hour 40 minutes after we'd left
and left the police station
and within 10 minutes i was contacted
off a 17 year old girl
who had been raped by him from the age
of 12
upwards she'd never told anybody in her
life that she'd been raped or abused by
him
and i was the first person that she
disclosed to um
i instantly knew that i needed to put
her in touch with the police if she was
willing to do that
um she did that and the following day
she went and gave a statement and
secured five counts of rape on him and
on the fourth of june just connie was
jailed for
eight years
so you know you can see just in that in
itself that's a real person that's a
real
12 year old who's had to live through
those times
and then just you know just because i
put a picture on a facebook page
what a strong inspirational young woman
we frequently get parents coming to us
who have got children and their children
have been contacted by a predator
they've tried to contact the police and
the police just haven't got the
resources to deal with it or
you know it's it's gonna take a while
for the police to deal with it
and they come to us so you know a
majority of what we do with
with the page is done behind closed
doors it's not
you know it's a it's a visible it's a
visible
entity but it's there's a lot more work
that goes on behind it things like
safeguarding things like
um you know making sure that the people
that
volunteer within my organization are
okay
and that you know that it's not getting
too much for him because it can become a
very very
dark stressful place to work how do you
present the evidence how do you how do
you pull the evidence together
um so the evidence is is
put together in sort of a paper form
so we'll have all of the the chat logs
so that's like the screenshots of the
conversation that's been had and then
from there we will
burn all the evidence onto a disc so as
soon as the police get hold of it they
can they can literally just put the disc
in
and put it all on to to their system um
and they're also provided with a
dvd copy of the
live video so literally we will record
the live
the laptop that i've i take with me will
then burn off a disc
for them so they've got a copy of the
live a copy of the evidence and then on
top of that they've
they've obviously got um the
video of of everything that's happened
how well do you know the law so i'm
fully aware of the law
in in terms of um what
a predator needs to do to commit an
offense
you know we've had over 70 cases that
i've gone through court and they've all
you know resulted in successful
prosecutions
the sex offences at 2003 is like a bible
tumor
just because i'm i'm quite ocd so i need
to make sure that all the eyes i
did all the t's across before i do
anything um and i was told by
the first police officer that i spoke to
you know he said
i'm not going to be able to stop you
doing this but
if you are going to continue doing it at
least make sure you're doing it the safe
way
and that's where we've got titles from
so it kind of stems from
the sex offenses that 2003 and then
what i'm going to say now is do you have
any children yourself
yeah yeah yeah and how do you keep tabs
on what they do um
it's funny enough you say that it's
funny enough you say that because
while i do what i do and i've you know
i've done it successfully for nearly
three years
predators are still able more than able
you know
my children my two boys have got
snapchat no not snapchat they've got
tiktok and instagram
i won't allow on facebook um
but their instagrams are linked to my
phone and
um the tit talks to check every day just
to you know make sure all the profiles
are locked down and stuff
um simply because i don't want
my children to live in a time and and
you know this again is another reason
why i do what i do
i don't want my kids living in a time
where they can't do what their friends
are doing because there's so many risks
outside
for me it's an education i'd rather
educate my kids and make sure that
they're safe and they know they're safe
um but you know it does happen a
predator was able to get through to my
son
and message him on instagram and and say
you know this was this was only
probably about two months ago and and
say oh you know i want you to send me
pictures i'll pay you money
um yeah it's mad and you know doing what
i do you'd think
that my um
children's accounts would be out of
reach and it's just that's not the case
what kind of techniques do we need to be
aware of the pedophiles would use
they will hide behind fake profiles they
will
quite often you know set up
instagram profiles of
celebrities and hide behind that and
if there's just so many different ways
you know it's
it's so so easy for a child to be
groomed online
you know even on platforms like whatsapp
all it takes is for one person to get
your child's contact number and they're
put into a into a group
you know a whatsapp group where they
could be sort of 20 or 30 pedophiles
just
start requesting pictures it's there's a
madness
it takes five minutes to check a child's
device literally five minutes
um there's not many you know there's
probably five or six apps that children
go on um that are the most popular
platforms and they're
also most popular for grooming so if
you've got a child that's on say
snapchat or instagram or whatsapp or
facebook
and you don't know who your child is
talking to then really you should know
who your child is talking to because
they could be speaking to anybody
um and for me that you know the whole
purpose of me coming in today is is to
try and reach out to parents that
the risks online are very very real and
your children are in danger if
they're left unsupervised on an iphone
or a tablet
my question is how real is the danger
real as as real as anything um
we had a case through the other day that
was a predator who'd sent an
eight-year-old
why an eight-year-old was on instagram i
don't know um but he was an
eight-year-old on instagram
and the parents had checked the device
thank
you know thankfully and
found that he'd send in decent images
not have children but of himself to an
eight-year-old child
when we've looked at his profile not the
child's profile the predator's profile
we've actually seen
that there's um a further 49 different
children
that are on his friends list and these
are real children's profiles
so what we've then had to do is is go
through the profiles and try and
research
who the parents are what school they go
to trying to pick up distinguishing
features
even things a little as like a you know
like a tie
from from high school the emblem that's
on a tie like we'll look for things like
that and see if we can trace it
um it turned out this this predator was
i don't know where he was but he was
one friend's request away from
having access to my son again um
the one of the well there was there was
a lot of girls in my area where i lived
that had been contacted
and um i had to contact their parents
and
make them aware one of the girls
literally lived at the bottom of the
street
so really really close to home the the
dangers are stupidly real you know
is that why you put your thumb up you
putting your thumb up kind of through me
i was like what
should open a sun some bed shopping here
so literally i've you know i set up a
profile
um not so long ago probably a week or
two ago
and already on that profile is 173
friends requests
and that's of a child you know that's it
that's the profile of a 12 year old girl
and pretty much all of them
are from england so
you know 173 friends requests
and i can guarantee that that some of
them will be linked to rings
pedophile rings yeah there's you know
they come from all different walks of
life
all different shapes all different sizes
all different ages
it's not you know there's there's no
unfortunately pedophiles on you know the
the guy stood outside on a dark night
with a trench coat and a pair of
binoculars like they can literally
be whoever they want to be behind a
profile so
yeah it's dangerous do you think the uk
is a problem i think the world has a
problem i think
it's just how can i say it's a systemic
infestation it's everywhere
you know you've only got to look at
things like the news to see the mps are
getting caught up in sex scandals and
you know cyril smith the whole rochdale
thing jimmy savile you know it's
it goes right the way up in society this
might be a strange question
but do you hate the predators
no no for me
all i want to do when i'm going out and
getting them it's not even about what
they've been doing online the law can
deal with that
that's a criminal offence that's you
know that that's the justice system
when i'm going out to stinger predator
the first thing i'm thinking about
is the safeguarding that will take place
on the back of that arrest
so the police will put safeguarding
measures in place social services will
be alerted
any children that has been immediately
round will be questioned and spoken to
as will the parents
to make sure that that you know the
predator has not done any
harm or significant there's no
significant risk to that child
so it's in in the first instance it's
about those children that are
immediately around the predator um
you know when it comes to the case and
stuff that's for the police to deal with
no never um i've pretty much now
dedicated my life to it because
you know we we are making a difference
we are
seeing that as a direct result of the
page being there and the awareness
that's generated
um you know we're seeing real results
and it
is quite possible i can say this is yeah
it's quite possibly the best therapy
that i've ever had
because it's exposure therapy every
single time i go out on the road apart
from today
i'm stood in front of a pedophile um
asking them why they're doing what
they're doing and i've never got the
answer i've never i'll never be able to
understand what they do but
um every time we we get
a result it's as if little mike gets a
little bit of peace
you know a little bit of uh you know a
little bit more of the jigsaw
slots into place why are you wearing
them because it's not about me
you know there's people that'll see this
that'll know who i am they know
you know there'll be people that'll see
this that live next door to me
so it i don't what i don't want is
people stopping me in the street and
saying oh my god you know you're a
pedophile
because i've seen all the other hunters
go down that road and i've seen
you know that the whole facebook persona
take over that's not me it's not who i
am
i'm just doing it because i can and
because i want to and it's the right
thing to do
so i believe in the the power of one um
for me when i
when i started on this journey i wanted
to try and stop another version of
myself being created through
through abuse um you know i know that
having lived the way i've lived for the
past
however many years it's you know it's
not easy to live with them kind of
demons it's not easy to to wake up in
the morning sometimes and like yourself
so
if i can stop one person just one person
with this
from becoming another version of me and
and having to
live the same kind of life that i have
then you know that that's the power of
one
you'll never truly understand how many
people you're reaching but as long as
it's one then you know job's done
um
me breathing
[Music]
and how many of those friends requests
are from middle eastern men i wonder
two percent i'd say two percent were
from middle eastern
98 white british males
just saying don't don't look at
stereotypes they're real types of bs